il ya une chose qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que certes les
américains ne sont pas présents
militairement en ukraine mais il ne faut
pas oublier que de la pologne à la
turquie les états unis disposent de
bases militaires qui constitue une ligne
de séparation entre l'europe et la zone
d'influencé russe c'est d'ailleurs ce
constat qui justifie aujourd'hui la
position de moscou puisque la seule
faille dans ce dispositif c'est
justement l'ukraine et dans une moindre
mesure la géorgie l'hypothèse selon
laquelle ces deux pays rejoindrait
l'alliance transatlantique est donc
légitimement très mal perçu par moscou
mais cela doit d'abord nous rappeler que
les américains ne sont pas aveugles dans
cette région les initiatives militaires
russes à la frontière ukrainienne sont
donc largement scruté par l' us air
force d'une part et par tous que les
états unis sont en mesure de mettre en
oeuvre dans le domaine du renseignement
c'est à dire beaucoup en cela ils
peuvent évidemment compter sur l'ukraine
qui a ouvert son espace aérien
évidemment aux américains mais également
dont les services de renseignement
communique quotidiennement avec les
services de renseignement américain et
le pentagone l'hypothèse selon laquelle
le territoire ukrainien serait infiltrée
par des unités spéciales russes afin de
déstabiliser le pays par des actions de
sabotage notamment comme ce qui est
évoqué et bien cette hypothèse n'est
rien d'autre que le relais par le
pentagone d'un renseignement d'origine
ukrainienne bien sûr